we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
over night whatever this is a fred from
florida and i'm commenting on is it
worth trying to change those people's
minds those drummers i'm a seven year
old man and i work two part-time jobs to
be able to pay my bills and i was
talking to a customer in an era one day
and i said something about having to
work until i can't walk anymore and she
she got very company put her hands on
her hips and stared up me and she said
don't you dare we criticize the
republicans for anything there's no
point in talking as folks like this at
all listen to thought Thank You number
one how guilty of a conscience must you
have that when you hear someone say i'm
going to have to work until i can't walk
anymore they interpret it as a criticism
of republicans right because if the
story is as you told it you didn't
mention republicans how guilty was that
woman's conscience about what
republicans are doing to the economy if
that's immediately what her mind meant
to but i do want to say one other thing
because every time i say it's not worth
trying to convince trump voters you
should try to win elections by getting
people to vote who didn't vote people
get mad and they say david you're not
encouraging debate i want to be a
hundred percent clear okay i encourage
debate on the program i invite guests
with dissenting opinions from mine and
we debate ideas we have phone callers on
and they are allowed to say whatever
they want and many of them disagree with
me and we debate ideas I encourage you
to debate ideas for education and
learning and edification and for the
furthering of critical thinking and
thought what I'm telling you is if
you've got a specific election that
you're working on if it's against the
re-election of Donald Trump or a Senate
race or whatever it is a much more
effective use of your time given that
you're you don't have an unlimited
number of hours in the day to focus on
getting non voters to the polls who you
don't need to convince
politically who already agree with you
that is way more effective and easier
than starting to go point/counterpoint
with committed Trump ideologues who are
not going to be convinced by facts we
know we know the work of Daniel Kahneman
we know the work of Dan Ariely they will
not be convinced by facts is a
combination of cognitive dissonance with
the reality that trying to be talked out
of views furthers often you're sort of
steadfastness in adhering to those views
so from an election strategy standpoint
I encourage you to work on get out the
vote not on debating trumpets in your
personal life for education in college
on programs
let's have debates I've always had
debates and I encourage it on today's
bonus show
Soylent Soylent meal replacement drinks
have been halted in terms of sales in
Canada because regulators say it calls
itself a meal replacement but it is not
a meal replacement according to their
standards twitter is going to start
labeling political posts political ads
with who bought them and how much they
spent and we'll also talk about both
alaska senators saying to donald trump
no no no please don't change the name of
mount denali back to mount mckinley
those stories and more on today's bonus
show two ways to get the bonus show
number one david pakman.com slash
membership number two patreon.com slash
david pakman show both ways to get
access to the bonus show sign up
contribute today and we'll speak to you
then